ladies and gentlemen the man who gave me
a C in directing 101 mr. Martin Scorsese
in two-time Oscar award-winning mr.
Robert De Niro
[Applause]
[Music]
the challenge is always the same how to
get the vision that's in your head onto
the screen no matter how clearly you
know what you want to say no matter how
powerful your intent no matter how vivid
the images in your mind's eye you still
need the combined talents of everyone
you're working with to make your vision
come true congratulations to all five
nominated directors and they are Oliver
Stone for born on the 4th of July
Woody Allen for crimes and misdemeanors
either wherefore Dead Poets Society
Kenneth Branagh
or Henry the fifth Jim Sheridan for my
look
and the Oscar goes to Oliver Stone born
on the 4th of July
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my deepest thanks for your
acknowledgement that Vietnam is not over
all some people say it is but that
Vietnam is a state of mind that
continues all over the world for as long
as men in his quest for power interfere
and the affairs of other men so many
things to give tonight I want to give it
to Ron Kovic for his largeness of heart
and to Tom Cruise for making Ron's dream
come true
into a great supporting cast in the
truth thankless meaning of the word to a
crew that never failed to Bob Richardson
and Bruno Rubio David Brenner John
Williams Alex ho Clayton Townsend Joe
Reedy to the people of Dallas Texas to
the warm people of the Philippines to
Tom Pollock and Universal Pictures to
Wiley and and Mike meant Minkler - Paula
Wagner my guardian angel and to
Elizabeth mine I John oak oh thank you
for this night
[Applause]